hey everyone i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where today we are talking about
the news that cyberpunk 2077 has been
delayed again
first up there's construction nearby so
you might hear that
second i'm pretty late to getting to
this news um a lot later than i usually
am to stories like this because i didn't
have any interest in making a video
about this
um i i wasn't on twitter until
way after the news came out today i
hadn't looked at social media until like
maybe like 1 pm
um but when that happened i was like oh
okay a news update
it's more the conversation surrounding
the thing that i wanted to talk about um
but you know for anyone who missed the
news
basically the cyberpunk 2077 twitter
account tweeted uh
this statement today so this is the
statement they tweeted this morning for
anyone who missed it um
i don't think i need to read the whole
thing necessarily i can leave a link if
you guys like but uh
basically says hey everyone today we
decided to move the release date of
cyberpunk 2077 by 21 days the new
release date is december 10th
most likely there are many emotions and
questions in your head so first and
foremost please accept our humble
apologies and then they go on to
basically talk about um how they're
having a challenge with trying to test
all nine versions of the game
because nine platforms is a lot it has
to run on xbox one slash
x compatibility on the xbox series s
slash
x the ps4 ps4 pro the compatibility on
ps5
pc and stadia or while working from home
um and then they do also elaborate here
which i really appreciated the
transparency of
um about how they said the game has gone
gold and that
gone gold into a lot of people means
that the game is ready or past
certification but basically
their point is well no we are still
obviously working on
a lot of things this doesn't surprise me
terribly um
because you know for anyone who doesn't
know i'm in the game i need to give you
that disclosure
um bias etc i'm also just very excited
about it i'm sitting in my
cyberpunk chair that cd projekt red
employee hand delivered to my apartment
i've spoken to a lot of people on the
dev team
at um cd projekt or cd projekt and i
very much get the impression that they
really want this game to be perfect um
they
i i i get the impression again that it
like mortifies them that they could
release a game that
that isn't in line with the vision that
they
had set out to give this game um more so
than any other dev team i've ever spoken
to
um so the delays don't surprise me and
this always comes back to the
the pressure of announcing release dates
i sort of just wish they never had in
the first place but
generally look my stance on a delay and
why i didn't feel the need to make this
video until i saw some other stuff
coming out around this
um is that i'm i'm pro delay you know
make your game better that's
straight up i get that it sucks for
people who've like
planned vacations or schedules around a
release date um at least they are giving
us
a significant amount of heads up that is
definitely unfortunate but generally
like
i'm always gonna say yeah delay the game
to make it better uh i can wait i can
100 wait
one part of this that is a little bit
sticky um before we sort of get to why i
decided to make this video at all
here is that apparently cd projekt red
uh devs didn't know
until today which i don't even know how
that works
internally this is from screen rant it
says it's been reported that developers
in cd projekt red didn't even know about
or sorry didn't know about the recent
delay of cyberpunk 2077 until the news
went live on twitter
the delay was announced earlier today on
twitter having been pushed back to
december 10th from an initially planned
released
release in november and i guess this is
a definitely nothing worth noting fans
are understandably upset at the news
especially because cd projekt
repeatedly promised that the game would
not be delayed again before it's
released industry-wide i just wish that
they wouldn't announce release dates
until they know
and i know that that's really
complicated for business reasons for
a publicly traded company like cd
projekt it is especially complicated
because you have
investors that you have to answer to you
are on the stock market they want a
release date so they know when all of
the money you've been spending on the
thing is due to get return and it is
more about
giving those people a release date than
it is about giving gamers a release date
so it's not like
a dumb thing pulled out of thin air it
is a business requirement
um that is really unfortunate but look
generally
i'm in support of a delay because i want
a better game the thing that's getting
me about this one specifically and is
something that is complicated to talk
about that i hope i don't phrase poorly
and i'm not gonna show these messages um
because i don't really wanna
you know drive any traffic to these
people so for anyone who doesn't know
uh the team has been crunching to work
on cyberpunk 2077 there has been crunch
it means they
are basically like admittedly
overworking their stuff to be able to
get this game out
crunch is uh i want to say an
unfortunate reality of the games
industry but i feel like that sets it
wrong
crunch is not mandatory and we
definitely talk about crunches though it
is in the
aaa gaming space um when in reality it
is
poor time management and um poor
production i don't mean time management
in terms of the individual developers i
mean like it is literally on the heads
of the producers and
the people who are setting their goals
for their teams to try to prevent crunch
from day one and the fact that it keeps
happening
means that these people the people who
are doing the planning of the time
management are making mistakes
not the devs i don't buy that excuse but
i also know that it is
extremely common i know that it is like
that's when i say a reality i don't want
to excuse it but i recognize that it is
something that
is almost expected um which sucks and
should not be the case
i can also say as someone who has been
in crunch you know
uh games media absolutely has crunch as
well uh just nobody cares when it's
media
crunch is pretty pretty broad in games
and i'm sure in other industries as well
here's the thing that i have seen today
that i take issue with
and maybe i'm you know a little bit too
close
to the source material um not where cd
projekt red is concerned i've not spoken
to any devs at cd projekt red about
crunch but i have spoken to people at
other studios
we seem to have created this thing in
video game culture
where when the community finds out about
crunch
and obviously a lot of people seem to
have assumed
uh that this news means that there will
be
more crunch for these developers which
is obviously very bad for their health
certainly not something that i support
the attitude is one that i'm just
finding very strange
again i don't want to show this on
screen so i'm just going to kind of talk
around it but i've seen
just a lot of today and i guess
previously
[ __ ] the studio and [ __ ] everyone who
works from them because they're
crunching
it's very intense and very hateful
um and some of it is explicitly directed
at the development team who are working
very hard to make a product
i have spoken to studios who um have
publicly had their working conditions
outed which they consider to be private
information that they don't want the
public to know
and when that happens and the public
turns on the entire studio
these people feel like all of their hard
work is for nothing
and that even though they are going to
continue working very hard
a because they have to which is a
problem with crunch and that's a whole
thing but b
in some cases some of these people want
to and that is you know again a very
complicated
discussion here that it's the manager's
job to stop people from overworking
i get all of that i'm not trying to
dismiss it just trying to provide
a different perspective from the one
that i keep seeing really but the just
basically
the the attacks that get directed at
developers who are already suffering
are just very strange to me like i i
literally saw someone say
[ __ ] everyone who works at cdpro.red it
serves them right or something like
along those lines like you're happy that
they're crunching and you hate them
for crunch attacking the entire studio
over having a culture where they have
potentially been forced to work hard
is a very strange approach you are
taking people who are already in a
difficult position
you probably work in the industry
because they're passionate because i
promise people don't get in a
game dev for money and that's just the
weirdest part about what i've seen today
like i've seen people saying serves them
right
or like have fun crunching for another
month like what
why are you attacking the developers for
this it's very
odd and and very aggressive and i feel
like
the community in a lot of cases has
taken this this crunch
conversation as a thing to get very
angry at an entire studio for
rather than specifically trying to place
blame on people in management when
they're talking about it and maybe
that's because you don't know who the
management
teams are you don't know exactly who is
at fault it almost feels like in some
cases when a story about crunch comes
out
some smaller parts of course this isn't
everyone of the game's community
um and in some cases even the people
reporting on these kinds of things
are like happy about
[ __ ] all over the dev team like it's
just very
strange it feels like a like haha
[ __ ] game dev scum serves you right
for having a studio
like what do you what this is my stance
about this entire thing
is yes delay the game make a better game
same token
my thoughts are not with the people like
me who are very excited to play this
game who have to wait a little bit
longer
my thoughts are with the dev team i hope
they are okay i hope everyone
is staying healthy and is staying
positive despite the
immense negative reaction to this news i
just want them to be all right
and and to not feel like they have even
more pressure at the expense of a delay
when in theory they also have internal
pressure you know i support
the team and would love to figure out a
way that the public could do something
about
situations like crunch like i don't know
what the action plan i can take is
because you know even the stance of
which i have discussed with some devs
again nobody at cd projekt red
but the stance of well then i'm not
buying the game if they crunch just
makes those people sad because they're
like well i worked so hard on this and
now you're not buying it at all
because of something that happened to
the studio even though
like i really am proud of my work it's
very complicated and i don't know what
to do but i don't think you know yelling
at game developers
um individually on twitter or or
just throwing all of this negativity
that way
is ever going to be the right option
i do think it's good that we speak about
crunch very negatively
and and that aaa studios are aware of
that and are concerned about their
crunch stories leaking or whatever else
because that is definitely a thing
that is public pressure about bad
working conditions
it's just when it's directed
specifically an entire development team
who are
i feel like the people who are making
the thing you're very excited about
who are the ones who are in the
difficult position of potentially being
overworked again
i don't know i've not spoken to anyone
on the team about this stuff i just have
noticed
today a weird celebration from some
parts of the community
being like haha you were crunching and
you had to delay anyway go [ __ ]
yourselves in a way that's just so
[Music]
why you know this video feels like a
mess but it is a difficult thing to talk
about um
because again i just want to say i fully
don't don't support crunch i don't want
anyone to go through this and my
thoughts are with the team and
i just hope everyone's okay and that
they know
that there are you know people really
excited about
cyberpunk like myself who are willing to
wait pretty much forever
uh i would prefer they delayed the game
longer frankly like delay it a year
so that the team can can finish making
the game to their standards
uh under the correct conditions
all right well can't wait to read the
comments on this one uh
i'm alana i'll see you guys next time
bye